training for sports gets you in a
mindset of being perfect of being exact
of being disciplined that carries over
exactly the space
I was drafted to play out of college to
the Detroit Lions in 1986 and then ended
up playing with the Dallas Cowboys as a
wide receiver on both teams and then I
was injured and it was until after I
left the NFL that I was interested in
becoming an astronaut
when you're launching from Kennedy Space
Center on millions of gallons of fuel
you are the most incredible rocket ride
to space and when you get there that
adrenaline is still raging through your
body and you have to calm down with it
so my training as an athlete help me
control that adrenaline rush and made me
focus and stay disciplined the first
time floating in space you're trying to
navigate what you're doing and where
you're going with your body but training
as an athlete has you understanding a
lot more about your body and you're
controlling these little micro
accelerations with your body as you push
off of things to make sure that you
don't damage anything when I decided to
become an astronaut I saw it was very
similar to being an NFL player because
there was teamwork involved the
quarterback is like the commander so the
quarterback sets the tone says we're
running this play of Leland you do the
down and out and then you know I'm gonna
throw you the ball the commander in the
mission says Leland is time for you to
take over this role you know we have a
malfunction I need you to do this on the
football field you have to cowboy it up
to get the win the win in space is when
you get your primary objectives done
like getting the Columbus laboratory
installed on the space station and the
real win it's when you get home
and land and you're safe and sound